optimism is a much better driver than
living in sort of a state of fear I am
Nicholas B with reason TV and today
we're talking with Max borders he's the
editor of The Freeman and he's the
co-founder of the voice and exit
conference held annually in Austin Texas
max thanks for talking to us thanks for
having me so talk about voice and exit
now this is an annual conference in
austin and the the kind of ethos of
voice and exit the ethos is interesting
i think the best way to describe it is
what would the world look like in a in a
post political age where we sort of we
start to collaborate more we start to
innovate and use entrepreneurship and
innovation instead of the political
process but it's not just about you know
political theory although that's
interesting aspect of it it's also how
what kind of interesting things you can
do with community that's perhaps tech
enabled what kind of interesting things
can you do with biohacking and personal
optimization neurofeedback and so on so
explore all avenues of human flourishing
really one of the main threads that ties
together everything you're doing is kind
of techno optimism it's where you're
looking you're oriented towards the
future and you're loving it you're not
afraid you're not wetting your pants
you're not wetting anybody else's pants
where does your techno optimism come
from and you know talk a little bit
about how it is actually helping the
third world in particular in terms of
disruptive innovation sure well on the
first part of the question and say
really what what so what drives me
personally techno optimism is on the one
hand I think people are either naturally
optimistic or pessimistic in a certain
way I don't know if its inherent or what
but I tend towards being an optimist and
so I want to bring that to my work it's
sort of natural as breathing optimism is
a much better driver than living in sort
of a state of fear up in the amygdala
part of the brain rather than why do you
think libertarianism you know I think
there's certainly a long strong strain
of pessimism end of paranoia or
you know kind of anger which and I think
that's true of everything on the
spectrum but you know why is that
attractive to libertarians that's a
great question and it's one of the
things i think if if you look at it
purely from an entrepreneurial
perspective it's like oh no one's doing
no one's doing hope and change in the
movement or a few people are right we
need more of that and that's why I'm so
happy we got to talk about it today
because optimism really drives movements
so talk a little bit about Argentina and
some of the ways in which you know
that's an example where technology is
really enabling kind of positive
disruptions exactly a clayton
christensen is the guy who really came
up with a term disruption to describe a
process whereby people who you know had
little means and little interest in
complicated technologies were really
driven to it but to something simple and
accessible first and that that would
suddenly ascend through the market
strata and begin to take it over that's
really what we're seeing with the
blockchain yeah we've got geeks here in
the United States who love to who love
it ideologically they want to play with
it and yet they live very comfortable
lives but when you are a desperately
poor person or you're living in a
country like Argentina that has a
thousand percent inflation you know
sudden adopting these technologies is of
necessity it's not it's not a question
then of you know whether it's cool or
trendy or whatever it's really about
necessity so it's I actually believe
that bitcoin is going to end the
technology that come out of it which you
guys are thoroughly covered it is really
going to happen in developing world
first and come back so is there a big
kind of Bitcoin surge in origin Tina
there is so I mean and it's a place like
that where you have a government that
you have a currency that is not
particularly stable you of high
inflation you have an unpredictable
government in terms of shutting this
down or shutting that down Bitcoin gives
people a way out of that immediate
circumstance to maintain or gain some
control over their everyday existence
well and it can be that it could be
contracts between people it can be land
title's there
other applications that people are
starting to look at particularly in
these places because they're seeing
mores lost effects happen and landing
right in their hands so if you've got
some somebody with a smartphone with no
other infrastructure and they're able to
delineate their land their property and
they're able to compare with each other
and suddenly have you know sort of
emergent law happening because of this
and communities of people who recognize
these land titles that is the basis of
essentially the common law being
introduced to the developing world
without the imprimatur of the leaders
there the corrupt and often you know
crony bought leaders and there's no it's
not like a Imperial nation coming in and
drawing lines which is what just
happened to and it's not to say that
doesn't work so for example you know
that's how Hong Kong was made they I
think it was the Chinese opium the opium
wars between Britain and China Hong Kong
emerged because they had sort of the
institutions as residue of colonialism
nobody wants to celebrate colonialism
but certainly what what they left behind
and good rules is is something to be
admired from everywhere in the world now
you've got situations where you can't
get that kind of toehold whether it be
through conquest or be through
convincing local governments Allah
Hondurans Xia DS legislation that you
can have these free cities sometimes you
have to build them in the cloud and
that's what's going on we're so this is
unfolding before our very eyes it's
extremely promising for the people in
the in the developing world so yes while
we we have reason to be sort of
suspicious and gloomy about and some an
impending crash that is likely to happen
maybe Peter Schiff will be proven right
again we also have a reason to be very
optimistic because so much of the
parallel structures for what is being
lost or being destroyed by government
policy is being recreated in the cloud
and people will migrate to the cloud on
mass if they can well we will leave it
there that's a kind of uplifting vision
of ascending to the clouds right it's
like the rapture but you don't have to
die to get there hallelujah yeah we've
been talking with Max borders he's the
editor in chief of the Freeman it's the
flagship publication of the foundation
for economic
education and he's also the co-founder
of voice and exit an annual conference
about innovation and change that's held
in Austin Texas max thanks for talking
to us thank you very much for having me
for reason TV i'm nick gillespie